Donald Trump has absolutely exploded in a
childish tantrum, the likes of which we've
not seen for a while over what is really a
very well-done ad that mirrors the style and
format of an old Ronald Reagan ad, but goes
right after Trump on his handling of Corona
virus.
And the Lincoln Project, which has created
the ad, is paying to run the ad during Tucker
Carlson's program on Fox News.
They're claiming that they are going to keep
running these ads as we close in on the November
election.
Now, we briefly talked yesterday about a few
tweets that Donald Trump sent about this.
And it is an ad by the Lincoln Project.
The Lincoln Project is an anti-Trump super
PAC.
George Conway funded it, founded and funded,
I think it rightly said and hilariously, George
Conaway is the husband of Trump's own adviser,
Kellyanne Conway.
I would love to know what a quiet night at
home is like with them at this point in time.
But in any case, it goes right after Trump
on Corona virus.
It's called Morning in America, but mourning
spelled M-O.
You are an Angie.
Let's take a look at the ad.
Listen to the ad.
It's just a minute long.
There's mourning in America today.
More than 60000 Americans have died from a
deadly virus.
Donald Trump ignored with the economy in shambles.
More than 26 million Americans are out of
work.
The worst economy in decades.
Trump bailed out Wall Street, but not Main
Street.
This afternoon, millions of Americans will
apply for unemployment with their savings
run out.
Many are giving up hope.
Millions worry that a loved one won't survive.
Covered 19, there's mourning in America and
under the leadership of Donald Trump.
Our country's weaker and sicker and poorer.
And now Americans are asking if we have another
four years like this.
Will there even be an America?
Paid for by the Lincoln Project, which is
responsible for the content of this advertising.
So like I said, they paid to run this during
Tucker Carlson show on Monday night, which
may be how Donald Trump first saw it, which
is just great.
I mean, you're going right after Trump in
the ad and you're also going right after Trump
by targeting the Fox News audience.
And what is good about this ad is that it
gets right at the heart of not just the lack
of empathy of Donald Trump's response to Corona
virus, reporting death numbers.
When he does as mere curiosities, essentially.
But it also goes after Trump's cronyism.
It goes after Trump's indifference.
It goes after Trump's inaction.
And it covers all of it.
And it gets to the economic issues as well.
And those may well be resonating with Republicans
in the context of who they're going to vote
for in November.
Sixty seconds of a really well-done ad and
it has sent Donald Trump into a complete and
total tailspin.
Trump started with a series of tweets close
to 1:00 in the morning early Tuesday morning,
where he wildly attacked George Conaway and
the other Republicans that are involved in
this project, saying, quote, Brace yourselves,
by the way.
Quote, A group of rhino Republicans who failed
badly 12 years ago.
Then again eight years ago and then got badly
beaten by me.
A political first timer four years ago have
copied no imagination.
The concept of an ad from Ronald Reagan, Morning
in America doing everything possible to get
even for all of their many failures.
You see, these loser types don't care about
252 new federal judges to great Supreme Court
justices.
A rebuilt military, a protected Second Amendment
biggest ever tax and regulation cuts and much
more.
I didn't use any of them because they don't
know how to win.
And their so-called Lincoln project is a disgrace
to Honest Abe.
I don't know what Kellyanne did to her deranged
loser of a husband.
Moonface, by the way, moonface interchangeably
a slur against Asian people.
Kelly kept George Conaway, I believe, is half
Filipino.
Also just a slur or an insult for people with
certain medical conditions.
Her deranged loser of a husband moonface.
But it must have been really bad.
John Weaver lost big for case.
Sick to me, crazed Rick Wilson lost for Evan
McMuffin McMullin to me.
Steve Schmidt and Reed Galvin lost for John
McCain.
Romney's campaign manager lost to Bego.
And Jennifer Horn got thrown out of the New
Hampshire Republican Party.
They're all losers.
But Abe Lincoln, Republican, is all smiles.
OK, so that's a mouthful.
That was close to 1 a.m. Tuesday morning,
but it continued yesterday during the day
with Donald Trump, then tweeting, quote, Most
of the money raised by the rhino losers of
the so-called Lincoln Project.
Remember, Rhino means Republican in name only
goes into their own pockets with what I've
done on judges, taxes, regulations, health
care, the military vets choice and protecting
our great Second Amendment.
They should all love Trump.
Problem is, I beat them all.
This is the guy who is close to being the
leader of the free world.
Were it not for Angela Merkel, he probably
would be.
This guy has access to nukes.
He has access to nukes.
He's in charge of responding to a 100 year
pandemic.
And this is what he's tweeting now.
Understand?
The ad is really a parody or a sort of satire
is Asian.
I don't know if that's a word, a satirising
of an old Ronald Reagan ad. Trump says that
they are copying it because they don't have
imagination.
No, that this is this is called satire.
This is called turning something around.
Morning in America was the Reagan ad.
Here is what is being mimicked.
This is the original Reagan ad.
It's morning in America.
Today, more men and women will go to work
than ever before in our country's history.
With interest rates at about half the record
highs of 1980.
Nearly 2000 families today will buy a new
home.
More than at any time in the past four years.
This afternoon.
Sixty five hundred young men and what will
be married.
And with inflation at less than half of what
it was just four years ago, they can move
forward with confidence to the future.
It's morning again in America.
And under the leadership of President Reagan,
our country is prouder and stronger.
And then why would we ever want to return
to where we were less than four short years
ago?
I find it funny that Trump attacks them for
copying it.
He doesn't seem to understand.
This isn't a lack of creativity.
This is taking a well-known ad that was positive
about a president and tweaking it to expose
the horrible leadership of Donald Trump.
Excellent job by the Lincoln Project.
Doesn't mean I agree with them.
I'm not rehabilitating the image of whoever
I did that.
But if they help us remove Trump for something
better than Trump, then that's a good thing.
And the next six months are going to be wild
if they keep putting these ads together.
We'll have more coverage of this ad on the
David Pakman show Instagram page at David
Pakman show.
Also this weekend, it's happening.
I am going to be participating in a transplant
of my tomato sprouts from indoors to outdoors
in my urban garden.
You're looking to follow the adventure.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
Very serious stuff.